Thank you all for being here.
My name is Shannon
Rose McAuliffe,
I'm the manager of the
student arts programs at MIT
and we're all here today to
kick off the 2020-2021 15K
creative arts competition.
I'm really excited to
introduce everybody.
We have team Elements
who are 15K first place
winners last year.
We've got Michael
and Maria, I've
Ellen Shakespear from 2018,
her venture is club Spaceus,
and then I've got fantastic
mentors, Nir Hindi
and John Corbiere
also joining to offer
some of their
perspectives about what
it's like to help these ventures
facilitate their success.
Let's start by going around.
Everybody give me a minute
long intro and a brief overview
of your venture.
We'll start with Elements.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Maria, I'm an
architect by training
and I recently
graduated from MIT,
from a master's of science
in architecture studies
and I'm co-founder of Elements.
So Elements is design
learning in a box,
we're developing at home
art and design curriculum
for students ages 10 to 14.
And we're hoping
to expand access
to design education by
putting creative curriculum
in the hands of students
around the world.
And beyond the
co-founder is Michael.
Everyone.
It's good to see
you this Sunday,
my name is Michael Stradley, I'm
also an architect by training,
I just finished a master
in science courses
in architectural design at MIT.
And the way Elements started,
Maria and I were working down
in the fall of 2019 and we were
just teaching a small design
seminar, looking at
experimental teaching
methods in architecture
and the idea felt strong,
our partnership felt
strong, and so we
built that kind of rush
collaboration into Elements.
We've been working
on that ever since.
Excellent.
Thank you both for
that introduction.
Why don't we pop
over to Ellen next.
Thanks Shannon, And thanks
for the invitation to be here.
It's a pleasure.
My name is Ellen and about
three years ago my co-founder
Stephanie and I
started our venture
which is called Spacers.
And Spacers works with
artists and property owners
to turn underused urban
space, whether that's
a vacant storefront
or perhaps a neglected
park in a neighborhood
into spaces for communities
to come together and for artists
and their work to be showcased.
And we do this because
we believe that when
artists have space in the
city everybody benefits.
And Stephy and I we started
it as architecture students
at MIT.
It was as simple as walking down
Mass Ave. on the way to studio
every morning and seeing
these vacant storefronts along
in Central Square and
Kendall, and thinking
there's got to be a better
way to use these spaces
and simultaneously knowing that
the city of Boston and cities
elsewhere continuously
need space for artists.
And so for the last
three and half years
we've been working on doing
that matching these spaces
with artists and
small businesses,
and entrepreneurs who need
the space to grow and thrive
in the city.
Obviously that's a strange thing
to be working on during COVID.
This idea of bringing
people together
indoors is something that
makes everybody kind of cringe
these days.
Rightly so, recently we've been
expanding the kinds of places
that we work as well.
So working outdoors with
communities and parks,
and parking lots even
this past summer we
put together a fare
for the city of Boston
that used to be more socially
distant and safe sites
to continue to
celebrate local art.
That's excellent.
Thank you so much.
I also look forward to hearing
a little bit more about that
as we continue with the panel.
Next up we have Neil Hindi.
Everyone.
Good afternoon
from Madrid, Spain,
my name is Neil coming
from original EO,
background in the
entrepreneurial,
business entrepreneurial.
The background
started two companies.
Today I always say
I kind of combine
two of my greatest passion,
health and entrepreneurship.
I'm the founder of
the Alpian, and what
I do with the
Alpian is basically
I take art as a way of
thinking because for me art
is always about the mindset.
It's not about the object.
And I help business
organization to bring art
more as a way of thinking
into specifically
the innovation, processes
in business organization.
And thanks Shannon for
inviting me to be here.
It's a pleasure having you here.
And next up we'll have our
last introduction from John.
Hi, everyone.
Thanks so much for having me.
My name is John Corbiere.
I run a animation and
design Studio in Toronto,
Canada called Thought
Cafe, as well as
a technology experiential
company called Future Talk.
We focus primarily
on factual content
course-based information
spreading essentially
and really, I've been
pushing the boundaries
in how we use augmented
reality and virtual reality
technologies to spread important
messages and help people,
especially in the
compassion realm understand
social and political issues.
Excellent.
Thank you all so much.
Now we're going to get into a
slightly deeper dive about each
of your ventures
and experiences,
and how they've related
to different aspects
that we try to
promote in the 15K.
So first up for
Michael and Maria,
I would love to hear an update
about your progress since May
and if you can discuss
things like the ramp project
that we did with arts at MIT,
and how your testing is going.
That would be great.
Sure.
Absolutely.
And May feels like a lifetime
ago but since then we've
kept ourselves pretty busy.
We just concluded
this program that you
referenced called RAMP.
Like all good
things at MIT, it's
an acronym that stands for
Remote Art-Making Pilot.
And so this is a six week kind
of experimental art and design
studio that Elements ran in
collaboration with the MIT
student art association.
So just following
the 15K competition,
a student art association
reached out to us.
They had the same problem is
everyone is teaching right now,
we need to do this
remotely, we won our support
from the robust student
art community at MIT.
How do we do this when we're
all distributed over the summer?
So we work closely
with them and we
developed this six
week pilot program that
was kind of unglamorous
and involved packing up
boxes with art
materials, shipping them
to people all
around the country,
and then meeting once a week
for a few hours to discuss
and critique one
another's creative work.
The goal of ramp for
us in addition to
doing some meaningful
teaching was
that it gave us the opportunity
to pilot a few to prototype
ideas that we have,
and get user feedback
from both undergraduate and
graduate students at MIT.
So we-- specifically we tested
three pieces of curriculum
that we hope to develop
over the coming 12 months,
those are going to become
products for live release.
The first was curriculum about
color material and pigment
formulation that people
are taking objects
from the world turning
them into paint,
the second was a kit that dealt
with cyanotype and photography
without the camera,
and the third
was a curriculum that looked
at rule-based and generative
drawing systems.
Yes, [INAUDIBLE] we're
working on building
a prelaunch
prototype, which will
be made available to
a limited audience
this winter, so it's one of the
kites that Michael mentioned.
It's the cyanotype and
photographic experiment kite,
and it explores the historical
photographic technique
of cyanotype, which allows
students to produce photographs
without a camera,
using only sunlight.
And this kite will include
light sensitive cyanotype sheets
as well as a series
of design challenges
and historical reference,
and a range of materials
that will help the
students explore
and experiment with
this technique.
Sounds fantastic--
If that sounds-- I have to
throw that this shameless plug
if this sounds compelling
to you or every young person
in your family or in
your kind of orbit.
We hope to get these
available before the holidays.
So we'll put the
link in the chat.
If you sign up with
your email, we'll
let you know just as soon as
we're finished working on it.
Excellent.
I'm also-- I neglected to
introduce my fantastic co-host
whose name is Theo Fields.
I introduced him in the
beginning of the last session
but I know that we've had
some new people join us.
So Theo is my
co-moderator and is also
going to be asking some
questions to everybody.
Yes, Thanks for the warm intro.
Some questions for Ellen,
a.k.a the Spacers team here.
So you mentioned having
outposts in New York City
and also kind of a move
to pivot your business
model a little bit, away
from indoor spaces more
towards outdoor spaces,
safe collective gathering.
Who have been your kind
of key partners in that
and what have been the
steps that have made
that successful and viable?
I think you are on mute cell.
Yes.
Classic.
Thanks for the
thoughtful question.
I think creative reframe
earlier mentioned
that nobody does this
type of work alone
and that is very much
true in our case.
There's a constellation of
partnerships and resources
we rely on every day.
I mean, not the least of which
are folks that you mentor
or that you meet rather
through organizations
and competitions like this.
Truly we are still
in touch with mentors
that we met through
this very competition,
we email them constantly
for big asks and little asks
and so there's mentors that we
keep in touch with who provide
us with resources and insight.
There are folks in the city
that have been particularly
essential for us working in the
real world in physical space
often requires us to think
about things like permitting,
licensing, how high can a
banner be et cetera, et cetera.
And we found a lot
of great resources
even just right in Boston.
I suppose I'll give
a quick shout out
to a group called the mayor's
office of new urban mechanics,
a division of the mayor's office
that is specifically focused
on R&D in the city
of Boston, perhaps
applicable to many teams.
These are folks who are
really interested in testing
and experimenting in the city
of Boston and best of all
they know exactly who
to put you in touch
with if there's a specific
division of the city that
might be applicable to
what you're working on.
So they've been a
huge resource for us
and then I think lastly
and maybe most importantly,
our customers.
We work with landlords
and we work with artists
and talking to them
constantly has provided us
with the kind of
invaluable insight
about what our next
step should be.
It's Stephanie and I
working full time at Spacers
but we could go around in
circles for hours, validating
one move or the other.
And then questioning
ourselves but the clarity
that we find when we
just pick up the phone
and talk to somebody who's
known us from the beginning, who
we've worked with
from the beginning,
and who is out
there in the world
experiencing a reality
that is unique to them
and you unique to them
as a customer of ours,
that has been illuminating.
So whether it's through surveys
or just picking up the phone
and talking to people,
are you comfortable
going inside of spaces yet?
Know like what does
that mean what would you
be comfortable with?
And just having a landscape of
folks that you can call and get
their feedback on has
been essential for us
as we both continue
to operate in Boston
and look elsewhere as well.
Fantastic.
I think there's a great
tick way for students,
which is real customer research,
real customer conversations.
This is crucial.
Speaking of students in the
competition, Hindi and John,
you guys have both
mentored students
in this competition before.
We were curious how
kind of fully developed
are some of the ideas when
you first encounter them
or when you first
encounter the student teams
and what is the most impactful
in helping them kind of refine,
reform those ideas as they
go through the competition?
John you want to go first
or you want me to go?
Why don't you go ahead
first, I'll go right after.
OK, great.
So I'll tell you something.
I mean, we keep
mentioning it but I
think one of the most
important thing is the team
and I always say that I prefer
an A team with the B idea,
than a B team with an A idea.
Because the A team
will know how to turn
around an idea and
the nature of startup
is that you change
on a constant basis.
So you have to be agile
and flexible in changing.
In other things
that kind of what
I try to do at
least with the teams
that I mentor is that
to really push them
into the validation phase.
Often we have
assumption in a startup
is basically a
bunch of assumptions
that you need to validate.
And I always encourage
them to leave the building.
What they say don't
stick to the sloven.
I think and I just mention it.
Having meaningful
conversations with a customer,
a professional customer
is super, super important
in order to validate a problem.
Because in the end
I tell them, you
don't want to find
yourself in SIS.
What we call a solution
in search of a problem.
You want to really make
sure that not only did you
have idea, that you have
an idea for the problem
that you're actually discover.
And I think that the
teams that actually
go outside of the comfort
zone and go outside
from the building and do
a speaking to customers.
Those are the ones that actually
able to make the progress
in the competition.
In the end, again, what I
try to do as a mentor is not
to provide an answer but
rather asking questions
to guide them through questions,
and challenge what they say
or challenge what they think.
And one of the exercises
that I ask my teams to do
is to actually think
about everything
that can go wrong
with your startup,
and try to think how are
you going to tackle it.
Because in the world
of startup everything
that can go wrong most
likely will go wrong.
So that's kind of
my perspective.
That was fantastic.
I'll give it a little shot.
The thing is well, I think one
of the most important things
you guys are coming
up with these ideas
is to share it and share
it with a lot of people.
That's we get really caught
up with holding ideas really
close to our hearts, and being
afraid that if we share it
with someone they
might take it from us.
So they might do it
quicker, but the reality
is there's probably
dozens, if not hundreds
of people that are coming
to the same conclusions
that you're coming
to at the same time.
And the only way
to win this race
is to do it as a
relay with a team
and to be really, really
confident about that team
but to not hold things in.
So test with as many
people as possible,
talk to people about
it, it's still going
to be your idea and your baby.
Try to solve a common
problem, a simple problem, not
a super complex one,
especially for this competition
because it's going
to be very difficult,
you're going to run
out of time and you
want something that is
simple but iterative
that you can really iterate on.
Think about areas that
give people anxieties.
How you can solve those
things, that kind of stuff
is becoming really,
really important right now
in the environment that
we're finding ourselves in.
So I think you guys should
really focus on that.
And then don't necessarily
focus on something
that you're good at.
Obviously you should
do something in an area
that you're good at but
it's too easy to be sort
of to get tunnel
vision, to be caught up
in this great idea
about something
that you already
know a lot about,
something that you're
already good at,
but generally that's not always
going to end up being the best
idea that you may be
able to come up with.
Sometimes the idea you least
expect it will come up.
So you have to be willing
to have a lot of ideas,
be willing to throw
them out quickly
and iterate and let
the process guide you
like an ocean swell
would guide you.
Control your ship,
set a destination
but know that the pathway there
isn't going to necessarily
be exactly what you expected.
So yeah, avoid tunnel
vision at all costs.
And that's what I have
to say about that.
These are all
fantastic insights.
This is great advice.
In the spirit of keeping
things fresh and lively
and again not succumbing
to Zoom fatigue,
I want to take a few minutes now
and do a full group lightning
round.
So we'll do two
minutes roughly each
and I'd like you all to tell us
what is one key piece of advice
or pearl of wisdom
that you would
give to prospective competitors
in this competition.
Let's go with Elements.
OK.
I can start.
So for me the one
key piece of advice
would be forming a team
that shares the same vision
and the same values as you do.
I think the team defines
the culture of the startup,
and that's why working with
people whose beliefs and values
align to yours is
so important to make
your ventures successful.
And I mean successful
not only in terms
of launching and
raising capital,
but also successful
at a personal level.
I think meaning that something
that is meaningful to you
and that you believe is
adding value to society.
So I think that would be--
also someone who you
do enjoy working with.
Because you're going to spend
a lot of time with them.
I think that would be mine.
Yeah, absolutely.
Obvious I agree
with all of that.
My advice, again, we're
very early [INAUDIBLE]
early on, so maybe don't
put too much stock in this
but I hope this is similar
to Jonathan's point, which
is you kind of can't be
precious with your idea
or what you're developing,
and my advice would
be to test the thing
as quickly as you can
and as often as you can.
Before Maria and I even--
before we had a name,
before we had any--
we were having
conversations about venture
with this startup
that, we were testing
our idea on captive
audiences, like
our peers in the
department of architecture
or junior high students
from the Cambridge area
that we volunteered to
quote and quote teach
and then we went and tested our
prototype curricula on them.
And every evening
it's embarrassing,
it's a little hard to put
unfinished, messy work out
into the world and be judged,
but we found that number one,
we gathered a ton of
useful information
that we were only
going to gather
by engaging with real
people, putting our product
back to the half baked as
it was in front of them.
And the other thing
that we realized
is that people were incredibly
forgiving and helpful
the moment that you explain this
is something I'm working on,
I value your opinion, or we
were talking to you because you
do have valuable insight and
perspective that we want access
to, and we think this
project is important
but we can't get there without
feedback from people like you.
The moment you say something
like that people buy
and they're forgiving.
The other thing is a rough
draft and we found that
from junior high school
students all the way up
to PhD candidates in MIT, people
were willing to take their time
and engage with your prototype
and give you earnest feedback.
So test early, test often, get
over the kind of shyness of it
and just see what people think
of what you're working on.
I think that's a
really important point.
I think especially for
a lot of creative people
it's sort of the intersection
of passion and vocation,
and that vulnerability can be
really difficult to overcome,
but you've got to get
out of that comfort zone
in order to thrive and
flourish in the way
that you're hoping to succeed.
So Ellen same question.
Yeah I think if I was
talking to myself two years
ago just starting out on
this I would remind myself
that no matter the outcome
of the competition,
you're going to learn more about
yourself than maybe even you
learn about your
venture in this process,
and that is a worthy
venture if you will.
I also think that it's
an incredible opportunity
to get outside of
the walls of MIT,
a place that can often be
very claustrophobic and inward
looking.
We used it as an
opportunity to finally get
to know neighbors that
we never interacted
with when we spent
all of our time
in building seven and studios.
And so I would use
it as an opportunity
to get to know yourself
better as a human,
as somebody who's going to
be joining the workforce,
as somebody who
works with others
no matter what happens on stage.
It is an incredible opportunity
to get to know yourself
a little bit better too.
I really appreciate that
answer because we're really
trying to facilitate
edification learning
betterment for
everybody at all stages,
and it shouldn't
be end game driven.
I think the focus and
the priority which
is becoming such a rich part
of the MIT Entrepreneurship
ecosystem is that there is
a spirit of inquisitiveness
and learning, and
that regardless of who
gets the great big check
at the end of the day,
ultimately there
should be value added
and mentorship for everybody.
So yes, absolutely.
Nir, your turn.
I'll use some of the
things that you mentioned.
I mean, for me the trick
again is not what's important.
Entrepreneurship it's a mindset
and it's a way of living.
Whether if you will succeed
this competition or no,
it's tools that will serve
you later on in life.
And the other part
I'd say that you
need to start at least
nine companies until you
succeed with the 10th.
So it's a long game
entrepreneurship.
Having said that it's super
important to use speed.
You need to make
as many iterations
as you can with very
limited time that you have.
In Creatives, I really
love to work with Creative.
There is one challenge
often is that they're
so passionate about what
they're doing, they're so
focus on the product, the
presentation of the service
that they forget there's
a customer outside.
So it's important to
have a great product
but make sure that you
speak to your customers.
And when you go
to your customers,
don't search for the
answer you want to hear.
Come open minded,
be active observer
in order to be able
to really understand
what they are looking for.
Sometimes they
don't know what they
want until you show it to them.
So that's my takeaway.
I really like that.
The insights that
everybody seems
to be sharing today
center around network,
partnerships, willingness to
fail, willingness to learn.
So John, do you have any
other follow ups for that?
Yeah, one of the things
I'll say is always keep
a really tight pulse on
socioeconomic political
situations.
And I mean in this case,
I think that for myself
and a lot of entrepreneurs
that I know COVID-19 quickly
had us pivot, but we
were in a situation
where we were kind of already
able to do that and some
of the technology projects
that we were working on for two
years out from now,
we ended up being
able to look at
those technologies
and find uses for
them now, where
they could provide assistance
and help in the education realm
and in some various other areas.
So yeah, having a
very strong pulse
on the adoption of
technology obviously
is really important,
but especially just
what's going on in the world
where are the anxieties?
Where are the problems that
can be solved and trying
to find that problem
that is relatively new
and doesn't have solutions yet
for it, but we can imagine,
will be in place for at
least the next decade.
That's what I would
really try to focus on.
I think it's very important
what you just said.
Things like ongoing
viability and sustainability.
It touches back
on what Ellen said
about thinking about
transcending the bounds of MIT.
When you're a member of
the big bad real world,
you still want your venture
to sustain and thrive
and having that mindset, that
forward thinking mindset,
I think is essential
toward ongoing success,
toward forging
deeper partnerships,
getting more buy in and
building your longevity.
So we've got about five
minutes left in the panel.
If anybody has any other
conversational points
or questions or
tidbits or things
that you feel like offering,
please let me know.
I don't necessarily want to end
early because we have a break,
I would love to
keep the pace going
and I know that we have so many
good ideas and great brains
in this room right now.
Oh it looks like we have
a question from Sida.
Go for it.
Hey, folks.
Thanks so much for taking the
time to share your experiences.
It's so inspirational
and so energizing.
So I love it.
My question is as someone
who has done some mentor
stuff related things in the past
but not quite in the art space.
I'm curious to understand
your perspectives
on what have you found
are unique barriers
and roadblocks in building
a startup in the art space,
and how did you or how did you
advise your mentees to overcome
those barriers?
For us the mentor?
For both mentors and founders.
I mean, I'll tell
you generally I
think that when you
come to a new space
there are no expense in the new.
By definition, if
it's new no one
can have experience in that.
So don't let the fact that
you are not art history
graduate or not an
artist by yourself,
to stop you from trying to
solve a problem that you think
exists.
Obviously as I will
keep going back
to one of the things I
insist on is make sure
that you validate
there is a problem.
And make sure that you speak.
If you are not an
artist by yourself,
speak as many and with
many artists as you can.
If you are not a technologist
speak to as many technologies
as you can.
I mean, that's
how you also learn
and what's beautiful
about entrepreneurship
or at least is what
the mindset you
need to adopt when it
comes to entrepreneurship.
Sometimes you don't know and
it's OK it's part of the game,
but you can also learn
all the information
in the world is accessible
almost for free.
So there are some things that
you can do by yourself in order
to close the gap.
That's my perspective.
I always believe in a
very active approach.
It's never about waiting for
someone to give it to you.
You need to be able to
step up to the game,
and start to actually--
Yeah.
Get comfortable with discomfort
because sometimes it's
not comfortable to go to people
and just that's my perspective.
I definitely share
that perspective.
The comfort zone thing
it keeps coming up
as a conversational point.
It's that growth mindset
is really important
and recognizing a Stephen
Sondheim says opportunity
is not a lengthy
visitor and you've
got to create your
own opportunities.
So we have any other thoughts
before we take another bit
of a Zoom stretch break?
Going once, going twice--
Another thing,
learned from Michael.
Entrepreneurs need to sell.
Immediately told us that we
will have the boxes available
by the end of the season.
So it's very important sales
skills are super, super
important as an entrepreneur
you always, always, always sell.
So good as to market it
immediately showed us
that we can buy the product
at the end of the month.
That was really important
turning around on a dime
that agility was one of the
most impressive aspects.
I am also one of the
most impressive elements
of Elements, if you will.
All right.
So
We're winding this down and
I'm sure Theo and I would
love to thank Nir and John,
Ellen, Maria, and Michael.
You've all offered some
really fantastic insights.
It's been a delight to
speak with all of you.
And thank you all.
Again, so much.